programming throwdown episode 156 pearl and regular expressions take it away jason hey everybody i'm sure most people have tried ChatGPT or at least have seen it and heard about it. Oh, my God. So everyone's heard about this by now. Even my parents are asking me about it and everything. So that's how you know it's really reached everybody. And I was looking into it and I thought this would be really cool if I could use it to scan my email. I had a bunch of ideas. I also had some ideas of maybe scanning some internal documents at work. But then, of course, all of my ideas either involve running it a zillion times, which I don't want to pay for, or running it at work, which is not a good idea.
So I was looking around at open source and I came across this, a couple of options. So there's one called GPT for all. It worked really, really well, amazingly well. I was really surprised because when the image thing came out, when DALI came out, the open source, you know, text to image stuff was not good at all. And it's still not really in a good place compared to the one from OpenAI. But this one is awesome. And you can download it onto your laptop or your desktop. It doesn't use that much RAM.
It's quantized. You don't need a supercomputer or anything. And you just ask it questions and it answers you. And it's pretty amazing. Like you just have it right there at your fingertips. I don't think it can run on a phone. I don't think it's that good, but it can run easily on most computers. The thing about GPT for all was when I went to like fine tune the model,une the model or train a new model, it didn't work. Basically, they have a bunch of config files that they didn't put into the repo and it's just not in a place where you could
really train it yourself. At least, I couldn't figure it out. Also, I think the repo is literally a week old. So it's not like it's really had a chance to go through its paces. So I found another one called Stanford Alpaca. And that one had a better repo and also kind of explained how both of them worked. So I'll kind of walk folks through that real quick. So if you remember from the chat GBT episode, you take these large language models,
you give the results to humans, the humans like rank them, and then you use reinforcement learning to like tune the model to try to return things that people would rank highly. That's really expensive, right? You have to pay all these people to do that. And so what these two projects did, which is really clever, is they basically just asked ChatGPT questions and then got their answer. And then they're basically trying to memorize
ChatGPT's answers. So they start with a large language model and they say oh when i ask this i expect that and that is you know chat gpt's answer now they don't like super overfit to that so it's like memorizing but they do that just to you know try to recover that sort of like the the ml term is bias but like try to recover that niche that ChatGPT had. And it works really well. I was impressed. The Stanford one, you have to download the large language model.
I got a BitTorrent of it. It was 300 gigabytes. So it downloaded over the night. Yeah. I don't even know why i'm doing this on my personal computer this is probably never gonna actually work i think you need like a some industrial strength computer but i'm gonna try it out and the model download over the night having a chance to to use it or anything but yeah it's it's very accessible way more accessible
than the image and video stuff and i think that's just because you know text is such an easier medium to operate in so is the idea like i mean i guess this stays like inference like running it and asking it questions locally so that you don't have to send personal or company data up to the cloud okay Okay, I get that. But is it accessible in a way where like, I want to fine tune it on something or have it think more thoughtfully? Like, I guess there's two things, like setting up that problem
and how difficult it is to set up fine tuning or training data. And then the second thing is actually like, do you need six GPUs and a bazillion gigabytes of GPU memory to be able to do those? Or can you actually do it on your computer given enough time? Yeah, I mean, I don't know yet. Well, I'm gonna have to figure it out. But the asking questions thing is very accessible.
Okay. But if you want to fine tune it, like, let's say you wanted to read your internal company wiki. And then, you know, be in a position where you could ask it questions like let's say you wanted to read your internal company wiki and then, you know, be in a position where you could ask it questions like, you know, what are the repositories in my company? Like the Git repositories in my company. That is the part that I haven't got to yet. They did say that you need a GPU with like a ton of RAM. I don't remember the exact amount, but it was an insane amount of memory for a
gpu so yeah i'm not totally sure what's the best way to fine-tune this like maybe you um take this 300 gigabyte file and you put it on amazon and then you you know borrow an expensive amazon machine sure but then that amazon machine now needs to be able to read your company wiki. Yeah, I have no idea how this is going to work. But I do think that there's something really powerful here. So this is the, I mean, like, I don't want to say killer because everyone has the next killer app for all of this. But if you could come up with a way of doing this very like straightforward having like internal search so this thing you mentioned maybe people aren't at big companies don't sort of like have this
problem or realize this problem this is a problem i run into constantly and you said just like what are our repositories but listening is one thing it's just like there's 5 000 tasks you need to do but you don't need to do all 5 000 routinely maybe your team or sub team doesn't have that knowledge. So even just finding the team to ask, or maybe they've even gone ahead and put it on the wiki, like here's how you set up your account and do all this. So just asking a question like, how do I do task A with data set B? You can't go to Google and type that in because what you need is, like you pointed out, you need to create an account at this, you know, go to this portal and fill in your information, which will create you this role, then you need to go to this web GitHub, clone this GitHub repository, and then run this command. And then your computer is
authenticated. And you do this. Asking a person on that team, if you could find the right team is actually super straightforward. But finding that team, getting them to like answer your call, and then forcing them to like, do that over and over again is like very difficult so everyone says why don't you put it up on a wiki they go well we did we put it on this wiki but like you need to know the search terms to put into right what system exactly to find that like it's a it's a just very difficult subtle problem and we tell folks on my team constantly, Oh, put this up on a webpage, put this in a wiki. And we do. And then we constantly field questions from other teams about like, well, why didn't you put it? And like we did here. Well, it's not in this form, or it's not linked into this hierarchy. And it's like, yeah, but how do I find out that you wanted it
there? Like, this is a very, very difficult problem, I would say for large companies. Yep. Yep. Yeah, totally right. You know, I think another cool idea here is you could make your own Alexa. I mean, it's not connected to the internet. So you know, it can't, you know, it can't do anything like that. But you could, you could make a little Raspberry Pi with a camera and not a camera, sorry, with a speaker, and a microphone. And then you could have a little Raspberry Pi somewhere in the living room. And you could say, Raspberry Pi, our humpback whales mammals or something. And it would just run this GPT for all.
And it would just tell you what it comes out. It'd be pretty cool. Do you know, is it capable? So one of the things that i've i actually just don't know and i've not found a good way to look up if i ask a question that it doesn't does it need to already know it in the data it was trained on or does it know how to like reach out get information synthesize that and then like riff on that so as an example like what's the weather going to be tomorrow it you it can't have trained on that right like so an example, like what's the weather going to be tomorrow? It can't have trained on
that, right? Like, so it would need to know how to reach out to a service, interpret that and give me like, is it capable of doing that? Like it can't if it doesn't have internet access. So, but if you gave it, does it know how to do that? Or are we not there yet? Not the open source one. So I think chat GPT has like third party apps, like plugins that you could install. It's not totally clear to me how that works. Like, like, how does chat GPT? So yeah, that's a good example. If you say what's the weather tomorrow? How does chat GPT know that it needs to, you know, query your weather plugin for that? Not totally sure. like might be kind of early days there where it's kind of you know hand coded like maybe you you look for certain triggers in the query like old school conversational ai stuff uh like yeah the kind of stuff we used when we played zork you know like that's probably what they're doing and they're saying oh you know someone asked you know someone asked a question that's like has a lot of pluses and divisions in it let's send this to the wolfram alpha plugin or
something but yeah that would be amazing if somehow you know and when you trained it so what you'd have to do to get this right is in the training data you you would have to have data for that particular plugin. So like right now, they give, let's say, all of Wikipedia to the large language model. Well, maybe they would also give 10,000 weather queries. And then the answer to those queries isn't like regular tokens, like the weather is clear, but it's actually like the answer is some special magic token that when chat GPT sees that magic token, it knows it needs to ask the weather people for something. Reaching out to the internet feels like a good segue to my first news article. So we'll take this as a forced time for news of the show. News.
So my first article that I have is an open letter from, I guess, the AI community at large. I mean, I won't name drop like the specific people. It's not super relevant. But asking for a six month pause in what they call giant AI experiments. I don't know how you feel, Jason. Maybe you can go in a second. But just sort of
like reading this article, this isn't my sort of domain. So I guess I would be a layman here sort of like thinking through like the general societal implications here as opposed to the specifics of AI, but asking for, you know, a six month pause and sort of making sure that we're ready, embraced for the impact of the, I guess, societal changes and the danger of some of this. I mean, famously, I guess, Elon Musk, who had a lot of early ties for open AI,
but seems to now be saying he's not very associated with them and has some disagreements with them, which we won't dig into here. But I think he sort of has famously always said that, that he's worried that there's a very real danger that, you know, general purpose AI would sort of pose a danger to society and to humans, the exact nature of which seems to just slide from, we can mock it for the silliness it does
today to like, all of a sudden, you know, somehow all of us are, you know, it figures out how to launch the nukes and we all die, right i think uh you know this six month pause is really interesting uh just as sort of like a a thought experiment in my mind which is like what does that amount to what is the like game theory of uh you know let's say somehow government steps in and enforces open ai as a u.s company and a u.s government you know to stop them but what about other countries? Doesn't that like they don't have it's a it's sort of like the kind of problem and not to like, you know, like the nuclear arms stuff, right? Like it's all the or climate change, you know, sort of policies,
all of these things are can only be whether you agree with them or not, they can only be as effective as the sort of enforcement or number of people who voluntarily, you know, sign up, right to doing it. That's why it's called global, right? Global warming, because the whole globe has to participate. Yeah, this is very like, what do they call it? I guess it sort of gets into tragedy of the commons, like no single country cares enough to stop what they're doing. And in common, okay, this is a side topic. So on this one, though, I think this is very interesting. And I was reading some analysis of it by Scott Aronson, who I didn't know, who's the person we've talked about before on the show, who does a lot of talk about quantum computers and sort of like, are the experiments you see coming out, are they actually quantum computer?
Or are they classical computers done in a quantum way? And sort of some of those nuances there and what that all means and p versus np and anyway so he talks about these kind of things i didn't realize he has been working recently at open ai on you know ai safety um but he sort of said and a personal response to some of this he has some good questions which is why six months not six years or six weeks like, what do we think is like the reason for six months? And just his analysis is like, this is a group of people signing on, but everyone actually kind of wants something different. And he had and I'll steal this story
from him. He had an anecdote that he talked to someone he knew from academia, who said they signed the letter and he asked them, he's like, no i completely disagree the letter he's like but i did a bunch of research for you know chat gpt4 and i like the next chat gpt5 comes out it ruins my research like i just need six months because that's the time iteration cycle of like getting my papers out so it's kind of funny because why that person signed it and why i saw i you know i don't know anything about it, but it was like, oh, Steve Wozniak signed this letter. Those two people probably have very different reasons and incentives for signing such an open letter. So this is an interesting sort of like news article. It's very prescient today for like, you know, all of these things are saying, is it really the end?
Is it the beginning? Is it a fundamental shift? Is it another personal 3D TV in your house for like, you know, it's just a fad and it's going to die out. VR is to be seen. We'll see what happens with that. But, you know, everyone's kind of like pontificating about what the implications of this all is. Yeah, I mean, I would, you know, when this show comes out, it'll be either on tax day or very close to tax day. So I think I would, I would probably sign it just so that I could get some tax reimbursement from all these professors who won't be working for six months. Like we should get some kind of a kickback. I think, yeah, I mean, it's true. The six month, you know, there's an interesting historical fact here, which is that countries that try to limit technology, it almost never works. Like, I think the one that comes to mind is when China banned the steam engine back in the in the 1800s they did it because they had almost like a
you know we have the taxi medallion system right you know they had a guild for you know stage coach you know and wagon transfers and all of that that was gilded and the steam engine would completely decimate all of those jobs and so so it's kind of like, you know, for automation reasons, they ban the steam engine. And some people say that it, it set them back like over a century because the steam engine was just so important to like the industrial revolution, which then caused like this like exponential growth in tech. I feel like, yeah, that might happen again here. You know, if someone tries to ban this technology, then whoever bans it might end up having a really hard time recovering from that later. I feel like the answer is almost never to pause or ban things, but to then build more things.
The constructive solution is almost always the long-term solution. I mean, to your point, you know, the six-month thing is by definition not a long-term solution. And so there was a Stanford, I think it was Stanford or Harvard, there was a researcher who, you know, using ChatGPT and a bunch of students submitted assignments, they wrote a classifier to classify whether it was written by ChatGPT or not. And so now like, you know, K through 12 teachers can run student reports through this classifier and it'll say whether ChatGPT wrote it
or how much of it, like what's the likelihood that ChatGPT wrote it and the spread, right? Like did it write all of it? Did it write just one part of it? so that i think that is really you know that entering that arms race is really you know the long-term solution i'll just say it and then drop it but you're mentioning of banning the the steam engine and setting things back is i guess like unintended kind of consequences and there's some analysis too about people sometimes,
again, not to keep doing it, but Elon Musk is always railing against short sellers on Tesla stock. And so there's like this equivalent with futures and options on various crops. And some by law are banned from having futures markets on them because they successfully lobbied that it would basically cause more volatility but in retrospect actually look there's more volatility in the ones without except then doubly look uh there's like where and how the distribution is shaped is different so like you get more very extreme price movements potentially in ones with options but these sort of like average
volatility i'm not a i'm gonna get my over my head here but like the the sort of like over time just the general volatility you see uh is reduced it's this is very like it's hard in these like very dynamic systems to predict what small changes will do yep yep yeah i totally agree we'll have to see what happens i mean they're up to uh what was it? Something like 2000 signatures. Yeah. 1800 signatures as of when we're recording. So probably when this comes out, they'll be up to 2000. Hey, maybe people here, it's like the like and subscribe. I'm just getting done. We're not advocating for you to go. Yeah. If you have to pick one, hit the subscribe button, hit the like button on this show uh but if you want to do both go for it we'll post the link in the show notes so related to this i have a article from
vice it says ai will smith eating spaghetti will haunt you for the rest of your life haunt is not the right adjective or adverb yeah it does stick with you though so you know we we all talked about dolly and we talked about on this show even dolly and image and things that take text and generate images so you could type in you know a dog in a space suit on the moon and it will generate an image like that one thing i've done that's really interesting is you can type in things that are abstractions like i i put in you know love wrapped in like swirls of happiness and then like it's like really interesting to see what kind of images come out of that but yeah these are just images so what's the next level the next dimension that is time and video and so someone has made the same kind of thing but with video
the thing about it is it's just you have to watch it. I mean, it can't really do it justice over the airwaves. But basically, it just moves in ways that are not Euclidean that really freak you out. And, you know, you look at the video. So someone put in Will Smith eating spaghetti. You look at the video and it's yeah it's definitely Will Smith eating spaghetti I mean it's it's completely unambiguous but but it's just so odd oh man what was your take when you first saw that I guess it's maybe it's like biased by if
someone who shares a link tells you this is funny or that this is like horrifying but it was like funny and so then when I watched it I'm like indeed this is like horrifying but it was like funny and so then when i watched it i'm like indeed this is like very funny but as jason when it takes a minute in my opinion it's like you said these concepts it definitely like oh okay will smith the famous actor if you know who it is you'll recognize you know or even if you don't know the name you would probably recognize the person but like it's not really the person so it's definitely picked up on like the attributes that make will smith recognizable but if you take like a screenshot like his face is distorted in very incorrect ways so it's like preserving the recognizability but it's clearly not like
stitching existing video or it's like hallucinating it right from like uh i guess that's like the latent space of anyways and so and there's definitely spaghetti but like the method is very unclear like he's not really using his hands or a fork it's like just going in like it's flying into his mouth it has like the spaghetti is going through his mouth like it's amazing it's just very like if you ask you know it's one of those things i always talk about like oh ai is so dumb you know it can't do it can't recognize a bird my five-year-old can recognize a bird but if you ever had kids or look at like kids pictures very interesting what they decide to draw and how they do recognize like like even to this day my kids are older asking like oh draw
a picture of a person sometimes they're missing a neck like they don't understand like the like what makes a person a person or the famous one uh is and i saw a clip where like i don't know if they did it often but a news reporter asked a bicyclist to adjust run one a like long rate like the tour de france kind of thing right and they come up with a piece of paper hey in 10 seconds can you draw a picture of a bicycle this is someone who spends like their life on a bicycle, like draw a picture of a bicycle. And it's actually very difficult for them to like put down the features that, you know, two wheels and a handlebar are great, but the geometry, the makeup, and this is not like a person who's never seen one before. It's someone who like tinkers hours, you know, weight savings, like all this stuff.
And they just like, can't kind of get it correctly. And this sort of the same thing here, like it's trained trained on these things but it doesn't get it quite right yeah have you ever tried to draw the layout of your house or your backyard for somebody like for you know a contractor or anything like that it's pretty much impossible like uh you know it's like you get the general thing like okay there's a bedroom and a bedroom connects this other room. And yeah, the bedroom is like smaller than the living room. But then it's like the thicknesses of the walls and stuff. Your house isn't shaped like a rectangle.
It's yeah. Yeah. It's like how thick the hallways are or how wide the hallways are, how thick the walls are in between the rooms. It's like we have zero concept of that in our in our mental model yeah it reminds me of if you ever watch like a slam video and when they close the loop so like slam is simultaneous localization and mapping so they're taking some you know camera or lidar through rooms and what you end up with is because it's not a hundred percent accurate in the reckoning that like rooms will be tilted and offset from each other but
then when you sort of like come at it via another path it sort of snaps into place and so i feel like what you're saying it's like if you drew the flow of your house like the graph connection is probably 100 accurate like which rooms connect to which rooms right but then you need like the shape and like some anchoring dimensions and then you could probably like deform it into it pretty accurately. But they always say this, like people live hundreds of years in a house and don't realize there's a three foot gap where like a million dollars is buried in the wall or whatever, because you just can't like spatially sort of like tell distances accurately enough to know that there's like some missing space in your room.
Yeah, that's totally right on. Completely unrelated. My next article, I guess it is images, so we got a theme going. So this image is someone posted a robust image compression from implementation from an old NASA paper. I think it was called ICER,
was what NASA had named it. Interestingly, when NASA developed stuff, it's like it and I'm going to be very careful. It basically should end up in the public domain because it's paid for by the public. I think there are some caveats made of the things that you say, oh, OK, so it needs to be if NASA, right? You think like space probes and robots on the surface of Mars and that kind of stuff. So the bandwidth is very limited. And that is definitely true. And it's very interesting to read how these videos and pictures we see get transmitted over time with budgets and allocations. And it's not like you have low speed connectivity all the time.
You have like bursts of low speed connectivity, and then long gaps. And so sending back initial stuff, and then refining it over time, which is very interesting. So the kind of cool part was this person who didn't have a, you know, as far as I can tell, like a ton of background in this rota C library for that implemented this, this image compression, where you can kind of give it a budget, and it'll try to do the best they can. But the other thing they pointed out that I found particularly interesting, probably just because of my background, is it being robust to like dropped packets. So we normally don't think about that. If you like take a JPEG image and you just like zero out one of the bytes randomly, or forbid, like delete the byte and shrink the file, like you're not going to get an image.
You actually just won't get anything. You're not going to get a crappy image. You just literally, it won't parse. You'll have an error. Your library, your computer might crash. I don't even know what'll happen. Hopefully not. There's just literally nothing in it. It's just built for reliable assumptions that all the data
is preserved. There might be a checksum. Maybe it'll know that it's not good and not render garbage, but you're certainly not going to get out just like a blurry image. And so what I thought was really cool here is thinking about a way of transmitting images or videos, which are sequences of images in a way where like, you don't have any assumption about, you know, packets getting through. Of course, if none get through, you get nothing. But like, you know, just randomly dropping one. none get through you get nothing but like sure you know just randomly dropping one i love the idea this is like uh this is really interesting i guess like the more packets you get the more clear it is kind of thing yeah and i think it
would be cool for if you imagine there's like really low bandwidth radio links you can get for like i think uh what is it i think laura is one of them l L-O-R-A, long range radio. But the bandwidth is very low. So they normally just use for like sensor reading, text message. But it would be cool to say like, if you set up a camera at an edge node, where maybe you had poor radio connectivity, and you wanted to put a camera there, and you wanted to like send back an image,
but your connection sometimes gets through and sometimes doesn't doesn't have a ton of bandwidth i think there's a lot of interesting opportunities there and it's funny how how we take for granted i saw the other day you can go to the store for sort of animal watching bird watching trail cameras uh like get a security camera that you like strapped to a tree that has like a cell phone subscription and it'll like upload when there's motion it'll like take a picture or a short video and upload it over your you know cell phone connection plan that you buy you know it's not a full plan but and it's just like wow and you just go to the store right i think you just go to the you know best buy or walmart or whatever and they have
one of these it's just like this is crazy to me how fast this sort of changed yeah i love how it says this library was designed with embedded systems in mind, but it should function on normal systems too. It's like saying, yeah, this was designed for Perl, but it'll work on normal languages as well. A little foreshadowing. The embedded stuff there, I think, is the call out because it's not
just the limited resources, but also things like embedded systems sometimes don't even have dynamic memory allocation. And you'd be surprised how few like off the shelf libraries will work if you say you're not allowed to run new or malloc. sense all right my news second news is called dig this vegas there's a bunch of these i found out there's one in texas i'm gonna try and go but basically these are kind of amusement parks where you get real life construction equipment so uh the one in vegas uh which a buddy of mine just came back from um they gave him an excavator and they they put a car like a you know a junkyard car on the ground and he gets to just demolish it and so like you as part of this experience they put you i think you start in like a skid steer and so you drive a skid steer through a track and then they have a bulldozer and you you know move some sand around all that and then they put you in an excavator and your job is to get to there's like yeah your goal is like there's inside the car there's a box and you have to get that box by like tearing
不仅是资源有限，有些嵌入式系统甚至连动态内存分配都没有。如果你说不允许运行 new 或 malloc，你就会惊讶于市面上有多少现成的库根本无法工作。好吧，我的第二个新闻叫做“去拉斯维加斯挖土”。我发现有很多这种地方，德州也有一个，我正打算去。基本上，这些都是游乐园，你可以操作现实生活中的工程机械。我在拉斯维加斯的那家，我一个朋友刚从那回来，他们给他一台挖掘机，然后在地上放了一辆车，比如废车场的报废汽车，让他去尽情摧毁。在这个体验中，我想你一开始是在一个滑移转向装载机里，你开着滑移转向装载机过弯，然后他们有一台推土机，你你知道的，移动一些沙子什么的，然后他们把你放进挖掘机，你的工作是去拿，车里面有一个盒子，你必须通过撕裂
the roof of the car or throwing it around or something. And so they put you in this really heavy duty equipment and you get to have fun for like two hours and do crazy stuff. So I thought this was really cool. There's one over here in Texas. I'm going to take the kids at some point, but I got a real kick out of this. If you're ever in Vegas or there's one in Minneapolis, there's a bunch of them. If it's something that you'd be interested in, find out the locations and try it out sometime. It sounded really, really awesome. I don't have any firsthand experience, but the idea just immediately clicked with me. So looking forward to trying this at some point. Are you going to give the disclosure about that being a sponsored segment? No. Yeah, they're not paying us unfortunately i wish they were yeah maybe they should be no yeah so this is uh totally uh unsolicited uh yeah we don't we don't uh push
汽车的车顶或者把车扔来扔去之类的方式来拿到那个盒子里面的东西。他们把你放在这些重型设备里，让你玩上大概两个小时，做一些疯狂的事情。所以我觉得这真的挺酷的。德州这边也有一个，我打算什么时候带孩子们去，但这让我觉得非常带劲。如果你去过拉斯维加斯，或者明尼阿波利斯也有一个，有很多这样的地方。如果这是你感兴趣的话，查一下地点，找时间去试试。听起来真的非常棒。我没有什么亲身体验，但这个想法立刻就吸引了我。所以很期待找时间去试试。你会不会透露这其实是一个赞助环节？没有。好吧，他们没有付钱给我们，不幸的是，我希望他们有。对，也许他们应该付。不，所以这完全是自发的，我们没有在这里推销
any product here so so uh it's all it's all legit i just teasy jason i've seen something similar i mean that one that sounds cool i've seen a similar one where i was somewhere and i guess it makes sense because it's a relatively cheap thing to do they go to i assume a thrift store i'm just gonna hope that they buy like damaged or broken you know tvs things that don't work anymore and then you pay and they put you in like a kind of like a jumpsuit like safety goggles and give you like a bat or a sledgehammer or an axe and like we will give you a room and in this room we're gonna have like you know dishes and a tv and like a sofa and you can just like go at it like smash them smash the but they probably don't want you smashing the walls but i assume they could build a fake wall if they wanted you
任何产品，所以这一切都是真的。我只是在开玩笑，杰森。我见过类似的东西。我的意思是，那个听起来很酷，我见过类似的，我在某个地方看到过。我想这说得通，因为这是一种相对便宜的做法。他们去，我猜是一家二手店，我希望他们买的是损坏的或坏掉的电视机，那些已经不能用的东西，然后你付钱，他们让你穿上连体衣、戴上安全护目镜，给你一根球棒、大锤或斧头，然后说：“我们会给你一个房间，在这个房间里会有盘子、电视和沙发，你可以尽管去砸它们。”但他们可能不想让你砸墙，不过我想如果他们想的话可以建一面假墙
to yeah so you pay for 15 minutes to just like take a sledgehammer to whatever's in this room and it's like wow apparently there's a you know malls today are having difficulties so i assume like rent is pretty low and so like they just put it it's a very low overhead operation to uh grab a bunch of junk from somewhere and put it in a room and charge people to go smash it yeah coincidentally i have a friend who's who's a physician uh or not is that the right word basically he's a surgeon sorry that's where i was, I have a friend who's a physician or not. Is that the right word? Basically, he's a surgeon.
是的，所以你花15分钟用大锤砸这个房间里的任何东西。这就像，哇，显然现在的商场经营困难，所以我猜租金相当低，所以这只是一个开销很低的运营，从某处抓一堆垃圾放进一个房间，然后收钱让人去砸。是的，巧合的是，我有一个朋友是个医生，或者说，那个词对不对？基本上，他是个外科医生，抱歉，我是说，我有朋友是个医生或者别的什么，那个词对不对？基本上，他是个外科医生。
Sorry. I have a friend who's a surgeon and he works for a hospital in downtown Orlando. He told me that they got someone in who went to one of these things that you're talking about. And basically, he swung the bat and it smashed the window of the car and a piece of glass like flew up and like cut an artery in his neck or something. So I'm pretty sure lesson learned. I'm sure they take out all the glass now. But there was when this like first was a thing, somebody got like really, really hurt. Just happened to be in Floridaida uh well on that happy
抱歉。我有个朋友是个外科医生，他在奥兰多市中心的一家医院工作。他告诉我，他们收治了一个去过你刚才说的这种地方的人。基本上，他挥动球棒砸碎了汽车的车窗，一块玻璃飞起来，割断了他脖子上的动脉之类的。所以我很确定，前车之鉴。我确信他们现在把所有的玻璃都清理掉了。但当这刚兴起的时候，有人受了非常非常重的伤。刚好发生在佛罗里达州。好吧，带着这个愉快的心情，
note it's time for a book of the show my book of the show is how to get in the hospital now my book this show is it doesn't have to be crazy at work so i found this book fascinating it's from dhh and that's what everyone calls them. But I'm going to look up the actual person's name here for posterity's sake. David Heinmeier Hansen and Jason Fried. So basically these are the two folks who made Basecamp, the co-founders of the productivity software Basecamp. So a bit of background here, Basecamp is completely bootstrapped. So there's no VCs, there's no strategic investors, there's none of that. And so, you know, that means there's zero pressure.
又到了本期图书推荐的时间。我推荐的书是《工作不必疯狂》（It Doesn't Have to be Crazy at Work）。我发现这本书非常迷人，作者是 DH Heinemeier Hansson 和 Jason Fried。每个人都这么叫他。不过为了保险起见，我要在这里查一下这个人的真实姓名。David Heinmeier Hansson 和 Jason Fried。基本上，这就是 Basecamp 的两位创始人，生产力软件 Basecamp 的联合创始人。这里简单介绍一下背景，Basecamp 是完全靠自有资金起步的。所以没有风险投资，没有战略投资者，什么都没有。这意味着零压力。
It's not a public company. And so all they really have to do is make enough revenue to cover their expenses in terms of staying afloat as a company. So that gives them like a very different perspective. But, you know, the book is all about a different experiments that they have tried, you know, in management, you know, they tried doing unlimited vacation, and they found out it was a terrible idea. And they tried this other thing, they tried our thing. And so it kind of like walks through their journey starting Basecamp, similar to the last book I recommended from Tony Fidel, it is rather prescriptive. I mean, they're constantly kind of telling you what to do, what not to do. And so you always have to take that with a grain of salt.
它不是一家上市公司。所以他们真正要做的，只是赚取足够的收入来支付公司的运营开支以维持生存。这让他们有了非常不同的视角。但是，这本书讲的是他们尝试过的一些不同的实验，比如在管理方面，他们尝试过无限休假，结果发现这是一个糟糕透顶的主意。他们还尝试了其他东西，尝试了我们的一些方法。所以它有点像是在回顾他们创立 Basecamp 的历程，类似于我上次推荐的托尼·法德尔（Tony Fadell）的书，它相当具有规范性。我的意思是，他们不断地告诉你该做什么，不该做什么。所以你总是得对此持保留态度。
I loved the anecdotes. They would talk about things that they did and what worked and what didn't. I mean, all the things that they tried, even the bad ideas, they make total sense. I mean, it seems completely reasonable to try any of these things. And so then hearing, you know, how they succeeded or failed or what, even the ones that succeeded, you know, how they had to make changes over time was fascinating. You know, I had a really great time reading it. I did finish the book a few weeks ago. So I read it cover to cover and it's relatively like homogenous. Every chapter is kind of like a different story. But once you've read the first chapter, you kind of see the pattern. And so yeah, really good content. Recommend it.
我非常喜欢书中的轶事。他们会谈论他们做过的事情，什么有效，什么无效。我的意思是，他们尝试过所有的事情，甚至是那些糟糕的主意，都完全说得通。尝试这些事情中的任何一件似乎都完全合情合理。所以听到他们是如何成功或失败的，或者即使是那些成功的事情，他们是如何随着时间做出改变的，这非常迷人。我读得很开心。我确实在几周前读完了这本书。我从头到尾读完了它，它相对来说比较同质化。每个章节都有点像一个不同的故事。但一旦你读了第一章，你就会发现其中的规律。所以，内容真的很棒。强烈推荐。
And you've now become immediately disgruntled with your current employer the the one that really stuck with me was the unlimited vacation because that what they talked about is exactly what i would think would happen in that situation which is you know some people will take like you know two three four weeks of vacation just like normal and then you have a hand like a percent of people who will take no vacation ever, because that's the type of mentality they have, and they get super burnt out. And so, you know, the nice thing about the, you know, you have three weeks of vacation or disappears is that at some point, someone's like working against their own interests by not taking it so that i thought
你现在立刻对你当前雇主感到不满了。真正触动我的是无限休假，因为他们谈到的情况正是我认为在那种情况下会发生的事情，也就是有些人会像正常人一样休假两、三、四周，然后有一小部分人根本不休假，因为这就是他们的心态，他们会变得超级精疲力竭。所以，有三周假期、不用就作废的好处在于，在某个时刻，如果有人不休假，那就是在违背自身的利益。所以我认为
that was pretty salient but yeah it was a great read all right awesome i have to check that out yeah i think you're right i think a lot of the some of this stuff seems like it would make sense right first time anyone hears about unlimited vacation i'm not gonna say anyone a lot of people probably like that would be amazing and then it's like yeah but you do realize if you just took if all you did was take vacation you're going to no longer have a job like and it's very difficult like you said to how do you deal with the i don't say guilt that's not the right like how do you deal with some managers being like yeah sure you know do whatever and other managers being like no and so yeah it does become very nuanced even vacation, you have like how much is sort of socially acceptable to take at
这一点非常深刻。不过是的，这是一本很棒的书。太棒了，我得去看看。是的，我想你是对的。我想很多这类事情初听起来好像挺有道理的。第一次听到有人说无限休假时，我不会说所有人，但很多人可能会觉得这太棒了。然后又会想，但你确实意识到如果你一直休假，你就会失业，对吧？而且正如你所说，处理这种事情非常困难。我不想说“负罪感”，这不是准确的词。你是如何应对某些经理说“没问题，随你便”，而其他经理说“不行”的情况的？所以这确实变得非常微妙。即使是休假，也有一个关于一次性休假多久在社会上才算“可以接受”的问题。
once. So most businesses either give you a set amount a year and it expires each year or you get some each year and it kind of builds up and then there's like a max and you, like you said, you have to either take it or lose it. But there is still some like, I don't want to say interaction negotiation about like, yes, you've earned four weeks of vacation because you haven't taken any for the last 18 months. But like taking it all at once is still a big ask rather than taking one week at a time. And so I think there's a lot of like a lot of difficulty in navigating the politics of that.
所以大多数公司要么每年给你固定额度的假期并且每年清零，要么你每年积攒一些假期，直到达到一个上限，然后正如你所说，你要么用掉它，要么就失去它。但仍然存在一些——我不想称之为互动或谈判——关于“是的，你已经积攒了四个月的假期，因为你在过去18个月里一直没有休假”的情况。但一次性把它们全休掉仍然是一个不小的要求，而不是一次休假一周。所以我认为在处理其中的办公室政治时会有很多很多困难。
Yeah, totally. I mean, one thing that is really controversial, but I stand by it is that I feel like in many ways it is a zero sum game. And so, you know, people will say, well, we have this, you know, we at Company X have this performance rubric. And if theoretically, you know, everyone was a greatly exceeded expectations, according to our rubric, then company X would get everyone a greatly exceeds expectation and everyone would get a three times bonus. But, you know, is it a coincidence that that never happens? Like, you know, do you really think it's a coincidence that there's always the same relative distribution every single time? And even if that did happen, people want to get promoted and the distribution of levels seems to stay the same all the time, right? So yeah, I do think that given that there are parts of it that are you know relatively zero sum or
完全同意。我的意思是，有一件非常有争议但我的立场很坚定的是，我觉得在很多方面这是一个零和博弈。所以，人们会说，我们在X公司有这样的绩效评估标准。如果按理论来说，根据我们的评估标准，每个人都“极大超越预期”，那么X公司就会给每个人都评“极大超越预期”，每个人都会得到三倍的奖金。但是，这从来没有发生过，难道这只是巧合吗？你真的认为每次都有相同的相对分布只是巧合吗？即使真的发生了这种情况，人们还是想要晋升，而职位级别的分布似乎一直都保持不变，对吧？所以是的，我确实认为，鉴于其中有些部分相对来说是零和的，或者
we'll say low low positive sum then there's going to be a class of people who will just be as competitive as humanly possible and what they'll like in the short term and in the long term they'll get as i said earlier like totally burnt out and so it's uh yeah it's really difficult. It's almost like getting someone to take medicine. It's bitter, but it's really important. Mine is a fiction book, which is The Prince of Fools by Mark Lawrence, which is the first in a series called The Red Queen's War. I haven't read the follow-up books, but this first book I did read, there was the, the oh I should have
我们称之为低正和，就会有一类人会表现得尽可能地具有竞技性，从短期和长期来看，他们会像我刚才所说的那样，变得彻底精疲力竭。所以这真的很难。这就像是劝人吃药一样。良药苦口，但它真的很重要。我读的是一本小说，是马克·劳伦斯的《愚者之王》（The Prince of Fools），这是《红后战争》（The Red Queen’s War）系列的第一本。我还没读后续的书，但第一本我确实读了。有那么一次，哦，我本该
looked up the silent no the sisters oh man why can't I think of the name anyways I had recommended books by Mark Lawrence before that were in a uh in a series and so this is another series by them and it's a pretty interesting take in sort of uh it's not science fiction but more fantasy oh definitely fantasy is when you're thinking holy sister or gray sister yeah that's one of them well there's a series there that's all part of the same oh you're right there's red sister yeah yeah i can't remember the name of the series though that was what i was searching for it failed me didn't have my notes together so the prince of fools is this red queen's war number one they're introducing sort of a new world this new concept i think mark warren says a pretty good job of of this sort of like setting a very interesting not grim world but kind of like
查一下“寂静修女”……天哪，我怎么想不起那个名字了？总之，我之前推荐过马克·劳伦斯写的一个系列的书。所以这是他的另一个系列，这是一个非常有趣的设定，有点像……这不是科幻小说，而是更偏向奇幻。哦，绝对是奇幻。当你想到《圣修女》（Holy Sister）或者《灰修女》（Grey Sister），对，那是其中之一。好吧，那里有一个系列都是同一个世界的。哦，你说得对，有《红修女》（Red Sister）。我记不得那个系列的名称了，这就是我刚才在搜寻的，结果没想起来，我没有把笔记准备好。所以《愚者之王》是《红后战争》的第一部。它们引入了一个全新的世界，一个全新的概念。我认为马克·劳伦斯在这方面做得很好，设定了一个非常有趣的、虽不说阴暗但有点像
things are are sort of like oppressive and problematic and you don't kind of always understand why or what all is going on and then as the story progresses you sort of get that feeling of like learning more and understanding the way the systems work and i think that's repeated here so i'm looking forward to reading the rest of this series. But there are kind of like two main characters here that are interesting dynamic because one is sort of like a privileged spoiled person. And the other is sort of like a very gruff, like raised on hard times,
压抑且充满问题、你不会总是理解原因或所有发生的事情的世界。然后随着故事的推进，你会有一种不断了解更多、理解系统运作方式的感觉。我认为这种感觉在这里得到了延续，所以我很期待阅读这个系列的其余部分。这里有两个主要角色，他们之间的动态非常有趣，因为一个是特权阶层，被宠坏的人；另一个是非常粗犷、历经艰难困苦、
kind of like a Norse warrior. And they kind of have to like end up going at things together and helping each other, even though like normally they wouldn't be associated. And so I found it a really nice read and looking forward to reading the rest of the series. Nice. So is this a completely separate thread or did you have to read the sister books first?
有点像北欧战士。尽管他们通常不会有交集，但他们最终不得不一起行动、互相帮助。所以我发现这是一次非常不错的阅读体验，我很期待阅读这个系列的其余部分。太棒了。所以这是一个完全独立的故事线，还是你必须先读修女系列的书？
No, I, well, I haven't yet even seen any references to the other one. So got it. I don't think it's in the same universe. I think that's the way of sort of saying it. Yeah, that makes sense. Oh, very cool. Is this, do you think this is a good one for people who are just getting into like, like,
不，我……嗯，我甚至还没有看到对另一本书的任何引用。所以，明白了。我不认为它在同一个宇宙里。我想这是可以说得通的。是的，这说得通。哦，太酷了。你觉得这本书适合那些刚开始接触，比如黑暗奇幻或史诗奇幻的人吗？
I guess, dark fantasy or epic fantasy? Oh, that's a good question. I don't know this is hard this is like asking we we answered this one but like it's still a hard one for me like what would you do today to get into programming and it's like when i got into it right and today it's like very different so it's hard so i've been reading fantasy for a very long time so i'm not sure that i'm called i'd have to to think. I'm sorry. I don't have a good response, Jason. No problem. Good question. I just don't know how to answer it. You know, I think maybe one answer is just, you know, any book that you pick up is going to be a good first
哦，这是个好问题。我不知道，这很难。这就像在问——我们虽然回答过这个问题，但对我来说依然很难——如果你今天要开始学编程，你会怎么做？这就像我当年入行时和现在的情况非常不同，所以很难说。我读奇幻小说已经有很长一段时间了，所以我不太确定自己是否有资格回答，我得想想。对不起，杰森，我没有好的回答。没关系，好问题。我只是不知道怎么回答。你知道，我想也许答案之一就是，你随手拿起的任何一本书都将是一本很好的入门
book. So if you're out there and you're looking for a really good hobby, you know, this is a great way to get started. I would say that having a book that pulls you in and regardless, you'll sort of make it through. I saw someone pointing out that there's a weird cultural thing, and I don't know how global it is, but that people have this thing when they start a book that they feel they got to finish. They want to finish it. it even if they don't like it they won't start a new book until they finish the first book and so like you get in this catch-22 where like it's hard to make it through this book so therefore you're not reading as much and they're like just very weird dynamic oh and i was like oh yeah actually i do feel this way like when i start a book i just really want to finish it and someone was pointing
书。所以如果你正在寻找一个真正好的爱好，这是一个很好的开始。我想说的是，有一本能吸引你的书，不管怎样，你都会把它读完。我看到有人指出，存在一种奇怪的文化现象，我不知道这有多普遍，那就是人们在开始读一本书时，会觉得必须把它读完。他们想要读完它，
out you should give it x pages or X hours of reading. And if you don't like it, just put it down. Don't finish it. Who cares? But I will say there have been some books that I really, really liked that took a long time to get into that like, you know, a third of the book was,
哪怕他们不喜欢。在读完第一本书之前，他们不会开始读新书。所以你就陷入了一种进退维谷的境地：这本书很难读下去，因此你读书变少了。他们说这是一种非常奇怪的动态。哦，当时我想，“哦，是的，其实我确实有这种感觉。当我开始读一本书时，我真的只想把它读完。”有人指出，你应该给它X页或X个小时的阅读时间。如果你不喜欢，就把它放下。不要读完它。谁在乎呢？但我要说的是，确实有一些我非常非常喜欢的书，花了好长时间才真正读进去。比如书的三分之一，
and I would love to critique them and say they should have done it differently or whatever. But it was sort of like, you probably wouldn't have had the payoff if you hadn't gone through the stuff. So I don't know how I feel about that assessment, but I definitely do fall into the camp of like, I don't, I want to finish a book. I don't like putting a book down, even if I don't like it, I've only done it once or twice. Yeah. See, I'm the opposite. I have a bunch of unfinished books.
我甚至很想去批判它们，说它们本应该用不同的方式处理等等。但这就好像，如果你没有经历那些内容，你可能就不会得到那种回报。所以我不知道自己对这种说法的看法如何，但我确实属于那种“我不想，我想读完一本书”的阵营。我不喜欢放下书，即使我不喜欢它。我只这么做过一两次。是的，你看，我正好相反。我有一堆没读完的书。
I mean, maybe, I think that there is a fault the other direction to where if I read a book and it's not really like holding my interest, then I'll just move on to the next book. And then part of it is if you check out a book from a library, then, you know, if you don't finish in time, it just goes back to the library. And that's, I think, a big cause of it. Well, if you like these books, you should definitely check out our affiliate links. So if you want to get into epic fantasy or you want to read about it doesn't have to be crazy at work, please go to our show notes and click the link that helps us out that I don't exactly know how Amazon does it. But if you click the link, Amazon rewards us through some way of doing it. So we appreciate that.
我的意思是，也许，我认为另一个极端也是个缺点。如果我读一本书，它并没有真正吸引我的兴趣，我就会直接去看下一本书。部分原因是，如果你从图书馆借了一本书，那么如果你没有按时读完，它就会被还回图书馆。我认为这是造成这种情况的一个主要原因。好吧，如果你喜欢这些书，你绝对应该查看我们的联盟链接。因此，如果你想了解史诗奇幻，或者想阅读《工作不必疯狂》，请前往我们的节目简介并点击链接，这会对我们有所帮助。我不太清楚亚马逊是如何运作的，但如果你点击链接，亚马逊会通过某种方式给我们回馈。所以我们对此表示感谢。
And if you don't want to go through or if you already have these books, you can support us through Patreon. Or even if you do have the books, you can always support us through Patreon. That is patreon.com slash programming throwdown. And we appreciate everyone's support. Yes, thank you to everyone. Yeah, with with that we have the tool of the show my tool of the show is actually a piece of hardware what yeah it's the remarkable two it's really interesting again we're not you know sponsored by them or anything so this is totally organic but uh it's very simple all it is is a e-ink display that has like you know a touch screen and it's somehow set up so that the pen can write to it
如果你不想通过链接购买，或者你已经有了这些书，你可以通过 Patreon 支持我们。或者即使你已经有了这些书，你也随时可以通过 Patreon 支持我们。网址是 patreon.com slash programming throwdown，我们感谢所有人的支持。是的，谢谢大家。好的，接下来是本期工具推荐环节。我推荐的工具其实是一个硬件，什么？是的，是 Remarkable 2。这真的很有趣，再次声明，我们没有接受他们的赞助或任何东西，所以这完全是自发的。但它非常简单，它所有的只是一个电子墨水屏，带有一个触摸屏，并且以某种方式进行了设置，使得触控笔可以在上面书写，
but like your your palm of your hand or your finger like don't accidentally mess things up so they have some palm rejection i think is what it's called um you can write really well it's extremely responsive and then on the back end, it can OCR your notes and turn them into text and everything. I haven't, to be honest, used any of those features. But the thing I really like about it is, you know, you can have very easy random access to all of your pages. So I used to use, you know, hold it up, even though we're an audio podcast, I'll hold it up anyways, just for my own sake. I used to use, you know, hold it up, even though we're an audio podcast, I'll hold it up anyways, just for my own sake. I used to use, you know, these little composition books.
但你的手掌或手指不会意外地弄乱它，所以它们有某种防误触功能，我想是这么叫的。你可以写得很流畅，响应速度极快。然后在后端，它可以对你的笔记进行 OCR（光学字符识别），把它们变成文本等等。老实说，我没有使用过任何这些功能。但我真正喜欢它的是，你可以非常轻松地随机访问你的所有页面。所以我以前用的是——我把它举起来，尽管我们是个音频播客，我还是把它举起来，就为了我自己——我以前用的是，这些小作文本。
And so I have like a ton of notes in them, things I want to remember, things from discussions I've had. But then, you know, I'm kind of flipping pages and this is just so much easier. So I have my notes, you know, I have each page in this kind of organized. And so if I want to go to another page, I just click on the name with the pen. I'm really digging it. Yeah, I mean, it's kind of pricey. I think it was, I didn't buy a cover or anything like that, but I still think it was something like $400 or $500.
所以我里面有大量的笔记，我想记住的事情，我进行过的讨论中的内容。但是后来，你知道的，我得翻页，而这个设备要轻松太多了。所以我有我的笔记，你知道的，我把这个里面的每一页都整理好了。如果我想去另一页，我只要用笔点击名字就行了。我真的很喜欢它。是的，我的意思是，它有点贵。我想它大概是，我没有买保护套之类的东西，但我还是觉得它大概要 400 到 500 美元。
But I'm getting a lot of use out of it, constantly taking notes at work. And so I feel like I am getting my money's worth. And overall, I'm just it's a beautiful experience. Do you have any thought of I saw Amazon released a Kindle version, the scribe that sounds very similar. Do you have any like, why one over the other one wasn't available when you bought the other? Yeah, it's a good question. The Kindle scribe was pretty new when i was looking and so you know it was a tough it was a tough debate i think ultimately i knew somebody who's really happy with the remarkable and so that's really what what pushed me in that direction i mean part of it is uh if i'm gonna read a book it'll almost
但我经常使用它，在工作中不断记笔记。所以我觉得我物有所值。总的来说，这是一种非常美妙的体验。你有没有考虑过……我看到亚马逊发布了 Kindle Scribe，听起来非常相似。你有没有想过为什么选这款而不是另一款？在你买的时候另一款还没发布吧？是的，这是一个好问题。我寻找的时候 Kindle Scribe 还很新，所以这是一个艰难的辩论。最终我知道有人对 Remarkable 非常满意，所以这确实是将我推向这个方向的原因。部分原因在于，如果我要读一本书，它几乎
certainly be an audiobook so So that was another factor. I think if you are a reader, the Kindle Scribe makes more sense. Like this thing, I think you can put PDFs on it, but it's not designed for that. It's not very convenient. So if you're going to read, I think Kindle Scribe might be a better option. I think it's a little bit cheaper too, but I haven't tried it, so I can't vouch for it. The Remark remarkable works really, really well and definitely get the pen with the eraser.
肯定会是一本有声书。所以这是另一个因素。我想如果你是一个书虫，Kindle Scribe 可能更有意义。这个设备，我想你可以在上面放 PDF，但它不是为此设计的，很不方便。所以如果你要阅读，我想 Kindle Scribe 可能是更好的选择。我想它也稍微便宜一点，但我没用过，所以我不能担保。Remarkable 真的很棒，一定要买带橡皮擦的笔。
So it costs a little bit extra, but you know, I'm constantly kind of going through and erasing different lines or replacing them and everything. Nice. I didn't realize we could do actual tools for tool of the show. My tool of the show is a game i checked i don't think i've recommended it before so here it is slay the spire this is not a new game this has
所以它会贵一点点，但你知道的，我经常需要擦除不同的行或替换它们等等。太棒了。我没意识到我们可以在节目中推荐真实的工具。我推荐的工具是一个游戏。我查了一下，觉得我以前好像没推荐过，所以就是它：《杀戮尖塔》（Slay the Spire）。这不是一个新游戏，它已经
been out for many years now um but i actually got back into it i was traveling and looking for something that was like uh easy enough to to sort of use while i was traveling on an airplane that kind of stuff. And this is a, I guess you'd call it a card game, but it's a card game that you wouldn't build physically. I guess they might try to do a version of it. And you sort of, I guess it's a rogue-like game or a rogue game in that you, as you progress through your journey, you can add cards to your hand. You can sort of figure out what you want to focus on you kind of build up points and then when you die you can you know improve your character in some way and i was having a really really difficult time like i was actually like kind of put it down
推出好多年了。但我最近又重新开始玩了。我当时在旅行，想找一款在飞机上旅行时很容易玩的那种游戏。这是一个——我想你会称之为卡牌游戏，但它不是那种你在现实中需要去组装的卡牌游戏。我想他们可能会尝试做一个实体版本。它有点像是一个Roguelike（类肉鸽）游戏，因为在你的旅程中，你可以把卡牌加入你的手牌。你可以弄清楚你想专注于什么，积累点分，当你死后，你可以以某种方式提升你的角色。我当时遇到了非常大的困难，实际上我甚至想放弃了。
i was playing it again again i just like i really sucked at it so i like did a little bit of googling for like some tips and realized like okay there's a few main characters that you kind of like unlock and actually the first one they were saying is much harder to feel progression about and so they were recommending the second one i picked up you know trying to play with the second character and sure enough like it clicked i was like oh i understand a lot more part of these games is playing through them enough to understand like what's ahead. Cause you're sort of making choices. And if you don't know what's up ahead, it's like, it's a sort of like talked about the book.
我一遍又一遍地玩，但我真的很擅长……哦不，我真的很菜。所以我上网搜了一些技巧，然后意识到，好吧，有几个主要角色需要解锁。事实上，他们说第一个角色很难感受到成长感，所以他们推荐了第二个角色。我试着用了第二个角色，果然，一下子就上手了。我想：哦，我懂了更多。这类游戏的一部分就是玩足够长的时间，去理解前面有什么在等着你。因为你在做选择，如果你不知道前面是什么，那就有点像——就像我们刚才谈到的书一样。
You got to play it enough to understand the dynamics so that you understand, like you can't just pick randomly and, or whatever looks cool. You got to kind of focus for a direction and it's hard to have a direction if you don't know like what the pacing is like or how often you can heal or these kinds of things anyways slays fire probably most people have heard about it or played it but um i enjoyed it and um once you sort of like get into it you can actually just like kind of play quickly and you sort of like get to more the strategy and a little less the like you know okay what do i do on each turn i'm looking at all my cards you know what they all say you can sort of play them very quickly and so the pace picks up oh very cool
你必须玩足够长的时间来理解游戏机制，这样你才能明白，你不能只是随机选择，或者挑看起来很酷的东西。你必须朝着一个方向努力，如果你不知道节奏是怎样的，或者你多久可以回血之类的信息，你就很难确立方向。无论如何，《杀戮尖塔》，可能大多数人都听说过或玩过，但我很喜欢它。一旦你上手了，你其实就可以玩得很快，更多地关注策略，而少花时间去想“好吧，我在这一回合该做什么，我在看所有的牌，我知道它们都写了什么”。你可以非常快地出牌，所以节奏会加快。哦，太酷了。
i've been getting into hearthstone which is somewhat similar although it's not episodic oh yeah another oldie but a goodie yeah wow yeah yeah it's uh it's good times i don't play with other people though because i'm not really competitive but uh the single player is actually pretty fun the nice thing about the single player is that you know that every level is is you know pretty either neutral or in your favor and you're not gonna get you know completely unbalanced you know cards i played similar exactly to as you describe hearthstone a while and i put it down and i i've not picked it up again i don't think you can really play it offline which to me is hard when like a lot of the times i can play is like when i'm on an airplane or whatever internet connectivity is
我最近在玩《炉石传说》（Hearthstone），这有点类似，尽管它不是分章节的。哦，对，又是一个老游戏，但依然很好玩。是的，确实挺好玩的。我不和其他人一起玩，因为我不是特别好胜，但单人模式其实相当有趣。单人模式的好处在于，你知道每一个关卡都是相当中立的或是对你有利的，你不会遇到完全不平衡的卡牌。我玩过《炉石传说》，和我刚才描述的完全一样，玩了一段时间后就放弃了。我再也没有捡起来过。我觉得你真的无法离线玩它，对我来说这很难，因为我经常能玩游戏的时候是在飞机上，或者是网络连接不太好的时候。
getting better but um i thought there was still like a compulsion to like get the reward loop unlock stuff to do at least some multiplayer gaming like oh you should go into a battle you should at least try to win one a day or one a week or during this time frame yeah you get these unlocks and even though they probably didn't matter because like you said they're like pre-canned for a lot of the single players i still felt like i was missing out and so i dropped it that makes sense all right on to pearl and regular expressions um what's your history with Perl? Like, have you used it for the purposes of scripting and kind of got more into in the early thing just using bash and it always felt like using something that came with it was a little easier and i was at the time a c programmer and so anyway so pearl sort of always floated on the
但我觉得仍然有一种强迫感，比如去完成奖励循环、解锁内容，至少要做一些多人游戏。比如：“你应该去打一局，你至少应该尝试一天赢一把或一周赢一把，或者在这个时间段内赢得比赛。”是的，你可以获得这些解锁奖励，尽管它们可能并不重要，因为就像你说的，很多单人模式的内容都是预先设定好的，但我仍然觉得自己错过了什么，所以我放弃了。这说得通。好的，接下来是 Perl 和正则表达式。你和 Perl 有什么历史渊源？比如，你曾用它来做脚本吗？你更早的时候是直接用 bash，总觉得用自带的东西会稍微简单一点。你当时是个 C 程序员，所以无论如何，Perl 总是游离在
periphery and you know yay old patrick would go onto the internet uh dog pile and search you know like something and get a Perl one liner, right? So rather than using sed and ox, someone would give me a Perl one liner, and I would have no clue what it said. And I would run it, but always sort of like bounced around where people would talk about using Perl and kind of interacting with but I just never sort of like got heavily into the development. But yeah, that was sort of like got heavily into the development but yeah that was sort of my has read about you it's about the same yeah i think you know i'd mainly use pearl as a a few kind of scripts to manipulate some text the big use case that i had for pearl is
边缘。你知道的，老派的帕特会去互联网上的 dog pile 搜索一些东西，然后得到一个 Perl 的单行命令，对吧？所以比起使用 sed 和 awk，有人会给我一个 Perl 的单行命令，而我完全不知道它是什么意思。我会运行它，但总是处于一种人们会谈论使用 Perl 并与之交互的边缘状态，但我从来没有真正深入进行过开发。不过，是的，差不多就是这样。我也读过关于它的书，情况差不多。是的，我想我主要把 Perl 用作编写一些脚本来处理文本。我使用 Perl 的最大场景是，
is where exactly where someone will come like i'll want to to, in a huge string or a huge, like, group of files, I want to, like, replace foo with var and all the files. And then you can use sed and all that. But sometimes it just, there's certain things, maybe, and I think it's gotten a lot better, but there was definitely a period of time where Perl regular expressions could do things that sed couldn't. And so it's like, at some point, you would try to do something that said couldn't and so it's like at some point you would try to do something that you read on the internet and it wouldn't work instead and you'd have to like go to pearl even actually pretty recent uh yeah the mac uh version of said the one that comes with mac or comes with freebsd oh this is yeah is like not doesn't have all the features. And so you have to go and get out of all.
就是那种有人会来找我，我想在一个巨大的字符串或一大群文件中，把所有文件中的 foo 替换成 bar。然后你可以用 sed 之类的工具。但有时，就是有某些特定情况——也许现在好多了——但在当时确实有一段时间，Perl 的正则表达式可以做到 sed 做不到的事情。所以就好像，在某些时候你会尝试做一些你在互联网上读到但用 sed 做不到的事情，然后你不得不转向 Perl。其实这甚至是很近的事。对，Mac 版本的 sed——Mac 或 FreeBSD 自带的那个——
Yeah. Yeah. You have to get GNU said, and then run G said, and so, so, you know, Pearl doesn't have that problem. Like Pearl has every version of Pearl, you know, reasonable version of Pearl has all the regular expression stuff. What we were researching for this show, I tried like looking for evidence or proof and I couldn't find any.
这个嘛，没有所有的功能。所以你必须去获取 GNU sed，然后运行 gsed。所以，你知道的，Perl 没有这个问题。Perl 的每一个版本——合理版本的 Perl——都有所有的正则表达式功能。当我们为这个节目做研究时，我试图寻找证据或证明，但我找不到任何证据。
But one of the things that I always sort of felt like that the earliest example of, I don't want to say dependency management, that's too strong. But having a programming language where it wasn't just what was sort of as shipped, that there was like, and not even like python talks about the concept of like batteries included and you know having all these things but today we think about python and no one that i know develops python without like having using i guess that's pi pi through pip or some other you know distribution environment where they go out and pull down modules node even probably more so with the node package manager yep but i going
但有一件事我一直觉得是依赖管理的最早例子——这么说太强了。但拥有一个编程语言，它不仅仅是出厂自带的内容，而是有……甚至不像 Python 谈论“自带电池”的概念和拥有所有这些东西，但今天我们想到 Python 时，我认识的每个人开发 Python 都会使用——我猜那是通过 pip 使用 PyPI，或者通过其他分发环境去下载模块。Node 更是如此，有 Node 包管理器。是的，但我追溯到
all the way back to like my earliest memories again couldn't find any defense of it but pearl had the the cpan and the cpan was like where you could go to get like the modules the downloads someone else had written something that did a thing kind of like plugins i guess or you know today we kind of know these are very common, but that was the Comprehensive Perl Archive Network. And it was a way for, you know, kind of like dynamically for you to grow the compatibility of your programming language and sort of pull down stuff that added capabilities or features or stuff that wouldn't have come out of the box. And again, I already kind of mentioned coming at this from like being a C programmer,
我最早的记忆——同样找不到任何支持它的证据——但 Perl 有 CPAN。CPAN 是你可以去获取模块、下载别人写好的实现某个功能的代码的地方，有点像插件，或者说，今天我们知道这些非常普遍，但那是 Comprehensive Perl Archive Network（全面 Perl 存档网络）。这是一种让你可以动态扩展编程语言兼容性、拉取能够增加功能或特性的东西的方式，这些东西本来不是开箱即用的。再次重申，我之前提到过，我是作为一个 C 程序员来看待这一点的，
even to this day, even in C++, this is still like not how things are done. Like in C++, you don't go like, oh, let me run some command. They do exist. It's just not the regular use of most C++ programmers. But like, you can't just, I think Conan is an example. Oh, I'm going to run this Conan command and download this other thing into my project
甚至直到今天，在 C++ 中，这依然不是做事的方式。比如在 C++ 中，你不会说：“哦，让我运行某个命令。”它们确实存在，只是不是大多数 C++ 程序员的常规用法。但你不能只是——我想 Conan 是个例子，“哦，我要运行这个 Conan 命令，把另一个东西下载到我的项目中，
and have all this other capability. That's just not how it's sort of done. But it was cool that Pearl had this. And I feel like this has become just the way it is today. But back when Pearl and the CPAN were kind of like in the zeitgeist, I feel like that was a pretty unique play. Yeah, totally right. Yeah, I think that was one of the great contributions of Perl was that it kind of created this network
并拥有所有这些其他功能。”这并不是它的运作方式。但 Perl 有这个功能，真的很酷。我觉得这已经成为了今天的常态，但在 Perl 和 CPAN 处于时代精神中心的时候，我觉得那是一个相当独特的举措。完全正确。是的，我认为 Perl 的伟大贡献之一在于它创造了这种网络
effect. I think that culminated with GitHub, where now you can create a project on GitHub. Everyone's looking on GitHub for projects, and it kind of creates this whole network. I was noticing the other day, unlike the GitHub thing, is how much easier it is to find snippets of code. We had open source projects before right now like no i'm an old person but you would go to like remember like sourceforge but like sourceforge but it had like uh was that an svn repository i don't even remember and you would sort of like you could clone it well that's not what it was called
效应。我认为这最终以 GitHub 达到了顶峰，现在你可以在 GitHub 上创建一个项目。每个人都在 GitHub 上寻找项目，这就创造了整个网络。我前几天注意到，与 GitHub 相比，寻找代码片段是多么容易。我们在现在之前就有开源项目了，好吧，不是现在，我是个老年人，但你会去，还记得 SourceForge 吗？就像 SourceForge 一样，但它有……那是个 SVN 仓库吗？我甚至不记得了。你会去，可以克隆它——好吧，那不叫克隆，
download it and then look at the source code but who who did that? Now when you search on GitHub, like the source code is just right there and you can just click, you can get some snippet, you can figure out how to do something, right? Like Stack Overflow snippet. I feel like it's just crazy how much different it is than kind of the way it used to be. Yeah, yeah, totally. Oh, the other thing that has always kind of stuck to me
下载它，然后查看源代码。但谁会那么做呢？现在当你搜索 GitHub 时，源代码就在那里，你可以直接点击，获取一些代码片段，你可以弄清楚如何做某事，对吧？就像 Stack Overflow 的代码片段一样。我觉得现在的变化和以前相比简直太疯狂了。是的，完全同意。哦，另一件一直让我对 Perl 念念不忘的事
about Perl is how amazon.com is built on Perl. And I would talk to people who work at Amazon and they would say, yeah, it's just, it's a, you know, I mean, obviously, you know, the database is not written in Pearl or something, but like, you know, the, the backend front end web stuff is all in Pearl. And that blew my mind because, you know, it's really an outlier. But yeah, I think I'm sure Amazon hires just tons and tons of Perl people even to this day. Is that like the Facebook runs on PHP, but it's sort of like a heavily, often heavily modified, whatever? Or do they really just like bog standard Perl? Do you know? They've got to have something right they've got to have
是 amazon.com 是用 Perl 构建的。我会和在亚马逊工作的人交谈，他们会说：“是的，这只是一个……我的意思是，很显然，数据库不是用 Perl 写的之类的一一但后端的网页前端全都是用 Perl 写的。”这让我大吃一惊，因为这确实是个异类。不过，我相信亚马逊即使在今天也雇用了大量的 Perl 人才。这就像 Facebook 运行在 PHP 上，但它是经过大量修改的版本吗？还是他们真的只是用标准得不能再标准的 Perl？你知道吗？他们肯定得有什么东西，
something because at that scale you know even if you make the compiler one percent faster that probably saves them enough money to justify you know some engineer working on that full-time but uh but yeah i think the the syntax is still very pearl like so I mean, getting back to our use case, you know, I primarily so Perl has this thing, they call it Perl dash pi. It's actually Perl, you know, dash p dash i dash e, you can just string them all together. And I'm going to try and see if I get this right. I think the I was interactive. I don't remember exactly what it was but basically you could do pearl dash pi you give it a regular expression and then you give it a directory and it will just execute that on the whole directory so you could do it's similar like set and off you know pearl dash pi you know substitute you know foo with bar on this directory, and it'll just go through and just take care of that for you. And I felt like, you know, definitely back in the day, that was extremely powerful and useful. Like imagine, you know, you have, let's say you have some text content, maybe it's
他们必须得有什么东西，因为在那个规模下，即使你把编译器提升百分之一的速度，可能就能为他们省下足够多的钱，来证明让某个工程师全职做这件事是合理的。但话又说回来，我认为语法仍然非常像 Perl。所以，回到我们的用例，你知道的，我主要——Perl 有个功能，他们叫它 Perl dash pi。实际上是 Perl `-p -i -e`，你可以把它们串联在一起。我试着看看能不能记对。我想 `-i` 是指 interactive（交互式）。我不记得具体是什么了，但基本上你可以用 `perl -pi`，给它一个正则表达式，然后给它一个目录，它就会在整个目录上执行该操作。所以你可以做到类似于 sed 和 awk 的功能，用 `perl -pi` 在这个目录下把 foo 替换成 bar，它就会直接遍历并为你处理好。我觉得，在当年这绝对是极其强大且有用的。想象一下，如果你有一些文本内容，也许是
coming out of your top command or something, and it's showing you your processes and what CPU they're using, and you have a log of this. And you want to put it into Excel. So you want to create like a comma separated value. So you want to take, you know, these, maybe it's tab separated. You want to make it comma separated. Perl-py will just knock that out for you very quickly. And you have set to knock and do that too. But it has the issues we talked about earlier.
从你的 top 命令或者别的命令输出结果，它会显示你的进程以及它们正在使用什么 CPU，你还有这些内容的日志。然后你想把它放进 Excel。所以你想创建一个类似于逗号分隔值的文件。所以你想把这些——也许是制表符分隔的。你想把它改成逗号分隔的。Perl-py 就能非常快地帮你搞定这个。set to knock 也能做到这一点。但它有我们刚才讨论过的那些问题。
I didn't realize it was three different commands just squished together like a p flag and i flag and an e flag it just happens to just felt like a word so today i learned but yeah very powerful and i think like this thing that you're pointing out which is inextricably kind of linked in with pearl and its history at least in my mind but i feel like most people I talk to is my, is no one talks about Pearl without talking about regular expressions. Like that is the, like even these use cases, we're sort of saying,
我以前没意识到那是三个不同的命令挤在一起，比如 p 标志、i 标志和 e 标志，它刚好拼得像个单词，所以今天又学到了新知识。不过确实非常强大，而且我觉得你指出的这一点，在我的印象中——至少在我看来，以及我和大多数人交流的感受是——没有人谈论 Perl 的时候不谈论正则表达式。就像那是——甚至连这些使用场景，我们刚才也说，
well, not the Amazon one, but the other ones Jason is pointing out is all about like regular expressions and pattern matching and replacing and, and that kind of workflow. Yeah, totally. And so that's one, you know, Perl really popularized regular expressions. But I would say, you know, in the long run, the regular expressions is really the lasting legacy.
好吧，亚马逊那个不算，但杰森指出的其他那些，全都是关于正则表达式、模式匹配、替换，以及诸如此类的工作流。对，完全是。所以这是其中一点，你知道的，Perl 确实把正则表达式发扬光大了。但我想说，从长远来看，正则表达式才是它真正留下的持久遗产。
And it's an extremely powerful system that really every engineer should learn and get familiar with. So for those who don't know or haven't ever used a regular expression before, can you maybe like go, is that even like a possible, like the 30,000, but like, what is a regular expression? Why do we have that as a named concept? Yeah, I think that, so find replace is obviously really important. You know, a simple example, let's say you created a variable or a function name is even a better example. You created a function a while back and, you know, the function was something like replace circle with square float or something is the name of
这是一个极其强大的系统，真的每个工程师都应该学习并熟悉它。所以对于那些不知道或者从来没用过正则表达式的人，你能大概讲讲——这甚至可能吗？比如从 3,000 英尺的高空俯瞰，到底什么是正则表达式？为什么我们要把它作为一个命名概念？对，我觉得，查找替换显然非常重要。你知道，举个简单的例子，假设你创建了一个变量，或者函数名其实是更好的例子。你不久前创建了一个函数，这个函数的名字大概是像
your function. And then later on, you find, oh, you know, I actually want to use doubles, I want to replace all the floats with doubles in my program. So I want to change this function name. But I also need to change all the people who are calling this function. So, you know, if your function name is unique enough, you could say you know you know just go in your text editor and say go in all the files and replace you know find circle with square replace circle with square float with replace circle with square double and so it goes to replace all those strings but sometimes you know when you're in the habit of doing that especially for refactoring you can get busted Like imagine if your function name was,
replace circle with square float 或者类似这样的函数名。然后过了一会儿，你发现，哦，其实我想用双精度浮点数（doubles），我想把程序里所有的单精度浮点数（floats）都换成双精度浮点数。所以我想改这个函数名。但我也需要修改所有调用这个函数的地方。所以，如果你的函数名足够独特，你可能会觉得，直接去文本编辑器里说，在所有文件里查找——把 circle with square float 替换成 replace circle with square double，然后它就会去替换所有这些字符串。但有时候，当你习惯这么做时，特别是在重构的时候，可能会出大问题。想象一下，如果你的函数名是，
you know, square root. And you're like, okay, I'm just going to go through my whole hard drive and replace square root or even this project or replace square root with something else. It's just going to be total pandemonium, right? You know, but if you could do something a little bit more advanced, like maybe, you know, there's places where you have, you know, square root in a comment, or there's places where you have square root, that's a variable name. So I want to say, like, let's actually look for a square root with an open parenthesis. And so you start getting more and more complicated, you know, find replace type things. Like another example is, maybe I want to find like contiguous sections of white space and replace all of it with a comma. So if I have, you know, Patrick space, space, space, space, space, Wheeler,
比如说 square root（平方根）。然后你心想，好吧，我打算遍历整个硬盘，把 square root 替换成别的，或者甚至在这个项目里把 square root 替换成别的。那简直会是一场彻底的灾难，对吧？不过，如果你能做一些更高级的事情，比如可能有些地方你的 square root 是写在注释里的，或者有些地方的 square root 是一个变量名。所以我想说，让我们实际去寻找一个后面跟着左括号的 square root。于是你开始编写越来越复杂的、查找替换类型的东西。另一个例子是，也许我想找到连续的空白区域，并把它们全部替换为一个逗号。所以如果我有“帕特里克”空格、空格、空格、空格、空格“惠勒”，
I don't want to have like comma, comma, comma, comma, comma. I just want to have one comma for that whole block, right? So you can imagine like a whole bunch of scenarios like this. And regular find or replace just can't do it. And so regular expressions were designed to do kind of text processing, more advanced text processing that we can't just simply do find or replace. Yeah, so I guess if I riff on that, if you go in your text editor and you, you know, special, special key F, whatever that is on your control or, or what is it command in Mac OS and, and you find something, it is like doing substring matching, right?
我不希望得到一堆逗号，比如逗号逗号逗号逗号逗号。我只希望整个区块只有一个逗号，对吧？所以你可以想象一堆这样的场景。而普通的查找或替换根本做不到这一点。因此，正则表达式就是为了处理这种文本处理、更高级的文本处理而设计的，这是我们通过简单的查找或替换无法实现的。对，所以我想顺着这个话题补充一点，如果你进入文本编辑器，然后按下那个特殊的键——F，不管在控制键还是 Mac OS 的 command 键上是哪个键——然后去查找某个东西，这就像是在做子字符串匹配，对吧？
So I was looking for like a contiguous set of characters. So one space or two spaces or a, then the letter B, what jason is calling out is sometimes that's not powerful enough because as an example if you wanted to eliminate a word in a comment and you don't know where in the comment it takes place and let's say i'll use the example of c++ and i we know that we use the backslash backslash at the start of the comments and in our project then what i want to say is i want to find backslash backslash, but then I want to skip to anywhere in that line where the word foo is,
所以我当时在找一组连续的字符。比如一个空格、两个空格，或者一个字母 a 接着一个字母 b。杰森刚才提到的是，有时候这还不够强大，因为举个例子，如果你想在注释里消除一个单词，而你不知道这个词在注释的什么位置，假设我以 C++ 为例，我们知道我们在项目的注释开头会使用双斜杠（\），然后我想表达的是，我想找到双斜杠，但随后我想跳过该行中任意位置的单词 foo，
and I want to replace it with the word bar. There's no way for you to do like control F or control R for find and replace. There's no way for you to specify in the normal default behavior of most of those to say, look here at the beginning of the line, skip some stuff, and then match this like that kind of matching, right supported. So a lot of them do have the option of going into a regular expression mode
并把它替换成单词 bar。你根本没办法通过按 Ctrl+F 或 Ctrl+R 来进行查找和替换。在绝大多数文本编辑器默认的普通行为中，你没办法指定：去看看这一行的开头，跳过一些内容，然后匹配这个——像这种匹配方式是不被支持的。所以它们中的很多确实提供了进入正则表达式模式的选项，
where you can you kind of write this. And that's a useful feature. But as Jason is pointing out, you need a special grammar or a special language for describing these more complex operations. Yeah, I actually want to interject like one kind of story here. When I was a junior engineer, I would get really, really frustrated when people would ask me to refactor things in pull requests. They would say like, change the name of this function or uh you know indent in this way or whatever and and the reason why i was getting so frustrated is because it took me a ton of time you know and especially if somebody said oh like actually i liked it so this happened to me one time where they said oh actually i liked it better the other way it had to do with um
在那种模式下你可以编写这种规则。这是一个很有用的功能。但正如杰森所指出的，你需要一种特殊的语法或特殊的语言来描述这些更复杂的的操作。对，其实我这里想插讲一个故事。当我还是个初级工程师的时候，每当别人在 Pull Request 里让我重构代码，我就会感到非常非常沮丧。他们会说，比如“改一下这个函数名”或者“用这种方式缩进”之类的。我之所以那么沮丧，是因为这花了我大量的时间，特别是如果有人说——哦，其实我更喜欢那样。这事我就遇到过一次，他们说：“哦，其实我更喜欢另一种方式。”这跟……有关，
there was a a variable that was plural and so they wanted me to make it plural. So let's just say make it simple. Like instead of apple, they wanted me to make it apples. And then when we actually looked at how it was used, they said, oh, no, I actually want to make it apple. And so I, you know, not knowing regular expressions was it was taking me hours to make this change. And I was getting really frustrated and it made me kind of frustrated at the whole refactoring thing in general to the point where i was kind of like look you know this is like i guess i'll put my researcher hat on like look you know the code works the numbers are like statistically accurate like i don't care whether the variable
有一个变量是复数形式，所以他们想让我把它改成复数。我们假设说得简单点。比如他们不想用 apple，而是想让它变成 apples。然后当我们实际查看它是如何被使用的时候，他们说：“哦，不，其实我还是想用 apple。”所以，由于我当时不懂正则表达式，我花了好几个小时才完成这个修改。我感到非常沮丧，这甚至让我对整个重构这件事情都产生了反感，以至于我当时的想法是：“听着，我得戴上研究员的面具了——看吧，代码能跑，数字在统计上也是准确的——我才不在乎变量名到底是 apple 还是 apples 呢，”
name is apple or apples right but you know, I do care about the code quality. It's just that I didn't have the tools to do that efficiently. And so I care about the code quality if it's going to take me five minutes or 10 minutes. I don't care about the code quality if it's going to take me a whole day or three days, right? And so I learned regular expressions way, way too late. And so I guess it's a public service announcement uh you know learn regular expressions you'll you'll you'll end up writing much better code as a result so one of the things about regular expressions that i never got into but
但是，你知道的，我确实在乎代码质量。只是我当时没有高效完成这项工作的工具。所以，如果花五分钟或十分钟，我在乎代码质量；如果要花一整天或三天，我可不在乎代码质量，对吧？所以我学正则表达式的时间实在是太晚太晚了。所以我想这是一个公益广告——去学正则表达式吧，结果你会写出好得多的代码。关于正则表达式，有一点我从来没深入钻研过，但
i always find interesting is there is like a formalism built out around them where, you know, we're describing very common end programmer operations where you want to run something, but sort of building parsers and the language and the grammars of all this, I don't think we're going to necessarily talk about here. But like, I just point out to people that that is like a thing that you will run into or hear people talking about various ways of kind of doing these. Or if you're ever going to write a domain specific language or some sort of thing where you're not just writing sort of a text input, but actually like something that helps script or run some of your programs, you'll kind of run into a lot of the more academic approaches and regular expressions are sort of
我一直觉得很有趣，那就是围绕它们建立了一套形式化理论。我们在这里描述的是非常常见的程序员终端操作，比如你想运行某些东西，但顺便构建解析器、语言以及所有这些文法，我觉得我们今天不一定会在这里讨论这些。但我想向大家指出的是，这确实是你将会遇到、或者听到人们用各种方式讨论的事情。或者如果你打算编写特定领域语言（DSL），或者某种不仅是编写文本文本输入、而是实际编写有助于脚本编写或运行某些程序的工具时，你会遇到许多更偏向学术的方法，而正则表达式可以说是
an end-use implementation, of which there are a couple of flavors. There's like a Unix flavor and the Perl flavor of exactly what the special characters are, but it's part of this larger academic grammar for sort of actually doing these kinds of operations, like pattern recognition and matching. Yep, yep. Another thing that that regular expressions does really well, that's hard to get
其中的一种终端实现，它有几种不同的风格。比如确切定义这些特殊字符的 Unix 风格和 Perl 风格，但它其实是更大的一套学术文法的一部分，用于实际执行诸如模式识别和匹配之类的操作。没错，没错。正则表达式另一个非常擅长、且在其他地方很难实现的功能，
anywhere else is is the grouping and the back references. And so the way this works is, you know, if you if you're also replacing, so if it's a find and replace, you might find a certain like, actually, Patrick, your example was pretty good. Like you might say, okay, find a line where it starts with, you know, a couple of slashes. And so I think there's, what is it the carrot sign, I think the carrot. So another thing about regular expressions, there's a ton of special characters. And you know, you can escape them out to treat the regular characters. But if you don't do that, they mean something completely different than look for a carrot. So if you see the carrot
就是分组和反向引用。它的工作原理是，如果你同时还在做替换——所以如果这是一个查找和替换，你可能会找到某个特定的……其实，帕特里克，你刚才举的例子挺好的。比如你可能会说，好的，找到一行以几个斜杠开头的内容。我想想，那个符号是什么，脱字符（caret）吗？关于正则表达式的另一点是，里面有大量的特殊字符。你可以用转义符把它们转义，当成普通字符来处理。但如果你不这样做，它们的含义就完全不是去寻找一个脱字符。所以如果你看到脱字符
symbol, it actually means this only matches if it's the beginning of the line. So you might say carrot slash slash dot star. And so dot means it could be any character star means any number of any characters or any number of whatever came before and then you know uh foo right so i'm looking for you know a string that starts with the slashes so it's a comment and then has something else and then now puts foo now if i want to replace that with something else right if i want to replace foo with bar right i need to keep all that other stuff like if i just say take that expression and replace it with bar it's gonna destroy the slashes and the dot star like my whole comment's going to be destroyed leading up to foo and i'm just getting
符号，它实际上的意思是：只有当它位于行首时才进行匹配。所以你可能会写 ^//.*。其中点（.）代表任意字符，星号（*）代表前面内容的任意数量，或者前面任何东西的任意数量，然后是，你知道的，foo。所以我在寻找一个以斜杠开头的字符串——也就是注释，然后中间有一些其他内容，最后是 foo。现在，如果我想把这部分替换成其他东西——如果我想把 foo 换成 bar，我需要保留所有其他那些内容。如果我只是简单地说“把那个表达式替换成 bar”，它就会毁掉斜杠和点星号——我直到 foo 为止的整段注释都会被毁掉，最后只剩下 bar。然后当我运行它时，
up with bar and then when i run that it's going to it's going to compile error because i lost the slashes right so you can create what's called a group so you can say look for something that starts with the slashes in the and anything you know a wild card and call that group one and then look for foo after that and then i want to replace that with group one whatever that and then bar, that's the back reference. And so you can do these like really intricate find replaces using regular expressions. And that ends up being extremely powerful. I think also like the common you're talking about refactoring, but like the common thing is like, if the thing you're trying to find and replace is like a substring of some other common
它会报编译错误，因为我把斜杠弄丢了。所以你可以创建一个所谓的分组。你可以说：寻找以斜杠开头的内容，以及任何通配符，并将这部分称为“分组 1”（group 1）；然后再寻找随后的 foo。接着我想用“分组 1”（无论它匹配到什么内容）加上 bar 来替换它，这就是反向引用。因此你可以用正则表达式执行这种非常复杂的查找和替换。这最终会变得极其强大。我觉得大家在谈论重构时，还有一个很常见的情况是：如果你试图查找和替换的东西，其实是你代码库中其他某个常见
thing in your code base i think this is where the regular expressions really help as jason's mentioning like capturing that like i'm looking for this only at the start of a word so it needs to follow a white space or it needs to be before an open paren but then also sometimes if you are trying to like apple to apples is a good example. Is that idempotent? What is the phrase where it's like, if you replace Apple with apples and you run that twice, you will get a lot of occurrences where you get apples S like Apple S S because Apple is a subset of the word apples.
东西的子字符串，我认为这正是正则表达式真正大显身手的地方。正如杰森所提到的，它可以精准捕获这些情况，比如“我只希望在单词开头寻找这个，所以它必须紧跟在空白字符后面，或者必须在开括号前面”。另外，有时候如果你试图进行像把 apple 替换成 apples 这样的操作，这也是个很好的例子。这具有幂等性吗？那个词怎么说来着？就是如果你把 Apple 替换成 apples，然后运行两次，你就会得到很多这样的结果：apples 变成 Apple S S（即 Apple SS），因为 Apple 是 apples 这个词的子集。
And so this is where it's really powerful but also these these back references and capturing this group of texts allowing you to repeat stuff so whatever you found after this like capture it and then like put it back twice like i want to repeat that thing or i want to put it as part of some other something so uh if i wanted to i wouldn't encourage you to do that but like if you were thinking about switching like uh from snake snake case, right? Is that right? Where it's the underscores to camel case. So it's like, if it's a start of the group or an underscore, then that whatever's next, like, imagine trying to do that, like Jason described, it would take you hours and hours to like, search your whole code base for underscores, ignore most of them them. Find the ones where there are variable names.
所以这正是正则表达式非常强大地方，但同时，这些反向引用和捕获文本分组的功能，也允许你重复某些内容——比如无论你在后面找到了什么，“把它捕获下来，然后放回两次”——我想重复那个东西，或者我想把它作为其他某个东西的一部分。所以，如果我想的话——虽然我不会鼓励你这么做——但如果你考虑把某种命名风格进行转换，比如从下划线命名法（snake case，对吧？是不是这个词？就是用下划线的这种）转成驼峰命名法（camel case）。所以如果它是一个分组的开头或者是一个下划线，那么接下来的东西……想象一下试着用杰森描述的那种方式去做这件事，你会花上整整好几个小时在整个代码库中搜索下划线，忽略掉其中绝大多数，
Like do these fixes. I'm not saying doing that with regular expressions at all. So it'd be really easy. That's probably could be reasonably tricky if you don't know what you're doing. But it would be at least, you know, approachable. Yep, yep. And there's definitely times where I've been able to use some clever regular expressions. And it is indistinguishable from magic.
只找出那些作为变量名的下划线，然后进行这些修复。我可不是说用正则表达式做这种事有多简单。那可能相当棘手，如果你不知道自己在做什么的话。但它至少会是（用正则的话）一种切实可行的方法。没错，没错。确实有几次我能够使用一些巧妙的正则表达式，那感觉简直和魔法分不开。
Or maybe indistinguishable from hours of labor there was one case in particular where we were using pytorch and pytorch has uh there's there's a build system called basil for building code and so we're using basil and pytorch has basil as well, but the Bazels didn't quite match. There were some differences. And you ended up having to basically, I ended up having to rename pretty much anything that had PyTorch in the build files. I had to kind of give it a prefix
或者也许和数小时的苦工分不开。有一个具体的案例是，我们当时在使用 PyTorch，PyTorch 有一个——有一个叫做 Bazel 的构建系统用于构建代码，所以我们在使用 Bazel，而 PyTorch 也使用了 Bazel，但两者的 Bazel 配置并不是完全匹配的。它们之间存在一些差异。最后你基本上不得不——我不得不把构建文件中几乎所有包含 PyTorch 的东西都进行重命名。我不得不给它加上某种前缀，
so that there wasn't a collision with this other thing. And so using some clever regexx i was able to do that and it ended up being a you know 65 000 line pr but it was just like in the pr description i just put the regex and so it's just like and i purposely like made a a pr that all it did was this regex. That way it's not like mixed in with real work, right? Yeah, and I mean, to do that by hand, right? 65,000, it would have been just intractable. We would have had to find another way around it. So regexes are super powerful,
这样就不会与另一个东西发生冲突。因此，利用一些巧妙的正则表达式，我成功做到了这一点。这最终是一个包含 65,000 行代码的 PR，但我只是在 PR 描述里写上了那个正则表达式。所以就像是……而且我故意创建了一个 PR，里面除了这个正则表达式之外什么都没做。这样它就不会和真正的业务代码混在一起，对吧？对，我的意思是，如果手工去做这件事——65,000 行代码，那简直是无法完成的任务。我们肯定得另辟蹊径。所以正则表达式超级强大，
highly recommend people learn them. And one really good way to do that is through these have you seen these patrick these websites where you can put in sample text and regexes and in real time on the website it'll you know show you the matches and the references and everything oh i've seen one that was like a tutorial but this one that you're you're you've got here in the show, this is like Godbolt, but for regular expressions. Oh, this is awesome. Wait, it's like what? Oh.
强烈推荐大家去学习。而学习它的一个非常好的方法是通过——帕特里克，你见过这种网站吗？你可以在里面输入样本文本和正则表达式，网站会实时向你展示匹配项、引用以及所有内容。哦，我见过那种作为教程的网站，但你现在在节目里展示的这个，这就像是 Godbolt 的正则表达式版本。哦，这太棒了！等等，它就像是……什么？哦。
No, do your thing first. It'll make sense. I'll tell you at the end. Godbolt is like you put in a C or C++ and it'll run it through a compiler and show you the internal workings of it, whether it succeeded or not. Do the decompiling.
不，你先说你的。这样才说得通。我最后再告诉你。Godbolt 的作用是，你输入 C 或 C++ 代码，它会通过编译器运行代码，并向你展示代码的内部工作原理，比如它是否成功编译。进行反编译。
Yeah. You can check if how loop unrolling does or doesn't work given different like compiler versions or pragmas oh that is super cool it settles a lot of debates about what's faster that's awesome yeah i'd never heard of that that's a really interesting is it called it's called godbolt? Godbolt, yeah. Okay, I just, T-I-L. Today I learned. Okay, sorry. That's a complete deception.
对。你可以检查在不同的编译器版本或编译指令（pragma）下，循环展开（loop unrolling）是如何或者没有如何工作的。哦，这太酷了！它平息了许多关于什么更快的争论，太棒了！对，我以前从没听说过那个，这真的很有趣。它叫什么？它叫 Godbolt 吗？Godbolt，是的。好吧，我今天又学到了新知识（TIL）。好吧，抱歉。这是一个完全题外的话题。
So, yeah, so Redneck Explorer, the way it works is, you know, you put a sample, and, you know, oh, by the way, one thing we didn't mention is you can even do multi-line matching. So, you know, even if you have something really complicated that's multi-line, you can get it done. It gets tricky, but it's doable. But you can put some sample text. And then as you're writing your regex, this is just running in the browser. It's not copying anything to the server or anything. While you're writing your regex, it's real time showing you, you know, here's what you're matching. Here's what the groups are, if you want to reference them in your replace string. And here's what the replace string looks like if you're doing a find replace. So if you're doing a find, it'll also, you know, tell you whether this line would have been found or not, or this part of this line. Extremely useful. I mean,
所以，是的，Regex 101 的工作原理是，你可以输入一个样本，而且，顺便说一句，我们没提到的一点是，你甚至可以进行多行匹配。所以，即使你有一些非常复杂的多行内容，它也能搞定。这虽然有点棘手，但完全可行。你可以输入一些样本文本。然后随着你编写正则表达式，它直接在浏览器中运行。它不会把任何东西复制到服务器上。当你在编写正则表达式时，它会实时向你展示：这是你匹配的内容，如果你想在替换字符串中引用它们，这些是分组，如果你在做查找替换，替换字符串看起来会是这样。所以如果你在做查找，它也会告诉你这一行或者这一行的这部分是否会被找到。极其有用。我的意思是，
one thing that you know, we didn't quite talk about with regex and pearl is or maybe maybe i'll just say regex it's extremely difficult to read you know reading a regex and trying to understand what it's doing is very very hard typically if i have a regex i'll almost always put a comment in front explaining like what i was trying to do with this regex because otherwise it's like you know slash bracket regular bracket abc b-z close bracket slash close bracket it's like it's it's it's almost like like hieroglyphics and so the nice thing is you can take any regex put it into this website and then you know put some sample text and see what matches and start to triage. That's definitely good advice.
有一点我们刚才没有完全谈到，那就是关于正则表达式和 Perl 的——或者也许我直说正则表达式吧——它极其难以阅读。阅读正则表达式并试图理解它在做什么非常非常困难。通常，如果我写了一个正则表达式，我几乎总是会在前面写一段注释，解释这个正则表达式的作用是什么，否则它看起来就像是——你知道的，斜杠、方括号、regular、括号、abc、bz、闭括号、斜杠、闭括号——它简直就像是象形文字。所以好的一点是，你可以把任何正则表达式放进这个网站，然后输入一些样本文本，看看什么能匹配，并开始进行分类。这绝对是个好建议。
Don't use regexes in your code to show up. If you use them, describe them. I'm not saying don't use them. That might be a bit too far. But I read some code base the other day that was using the ternary operator you know where you like put a boolean expression and then if it's true you do the first thing and if it's false you do the second thing and it's like a way of writing one-liners it almost never is not replaceable with an if else and so it was very frustrating because it takes 30 seconds to read what it's
不要在代码里直接扔出一个神秘的正则表达式。如果要用，就描述一下。我不是说不要用。那样可能有点过头了。但我前几天看了一些代码库，里面使用了三元运算符——你知道的，就是你放一个布尔表达式，如果为真就执行第一件事，如果为假就执行第二件事，这是一种编写单行代码的方法。它几乎总是可以用 if-else 来代替。所以这非常令人沮丧，因为阅读它所表达的含义需要花 30 秒，
saying instead of the you know five seconds of reading the if-else statement and they didn't write a comment they didn't you know anything it's like reading the if-else statement, and they didn't write a comment, they didn't, you know, anything. It's like, ah, why? And the red flag is the same thing. Even if you know what you're doing, you also, if you want someone to review it, not saying what you think it does requires the person to decompile it in their head, determine if that matches what they think the code should be doing. It's an extra step. If you write what you think it's doing, then they can just check that it matches that and then proceed. And that's actually just like a much better approach.
而阅读 if-else 语句只需要 5 秒钟，而且他们没有写注释，也没有做任何说明……就像是阅读 if-else 语句只需要 5 秒，而他们不写注释，也不做任何说明。就让人不禁感叹：啊？为什么？正则表达式也是一样。即使你懂自己在做什么，如果你想让别人帮你 Review，如果不说明你认为它能实现什么，就会迫使审阅者在脑海中对它进行反编译，来判断这是否符合他们认为代码应该做的事情。这是一个额外的步骤。如果你写明了你认为它在做什么，那么他们只需检查它是否符合那个描述，然后就可以继续了。这其实是一种好得多的方法。
Yep, yep. I've started even, I don't know if the one I linked has this. I'm pretty sure it does. But as you're going through, you can, or maybe there's a button somewhere. There's basically a button where you can share the state of your regex you know exploration so so if you put in some sample text and you put in
没错，没错。我甚至已经开始——我不知道我链接的那个网站有没有这个功能。我确信它是有的。但在你操作的过程中，你可以，或者某个地方有一个按钮。基本上有一个按钮，你可以分享你的正则表达式探索的状态，
uh you know a regex you can click this button now i you know i do think clicking the button causes them to save the sample text so if your if your sample texts are like government secrets or something that might not be a good idea. But you can click this, create like a shortcut URL, and then you could put that URL in the source code comments and say, this is the intent here. That's even better because now it takes people straight to that regex and they can see the decompiled result. I've often now gotten in the habit of putting either links to something like this or links to Wolfram Alpha. You'll see this in code all the time where it's like angle equals and then it's like cosine divided by this times this and then to the power of that. And then people
你知道的——如果你输入了一些样本文本，并且输入了一个正则表达式，你可以点击这个按钮。不过，我确实认为点击这个按钮会让他们保存样本文本，所以如果你的样本文本包含政府机密之类的内容，那可能不是个好主意。但你可以点击它，创建一个类似快捷方式的 URL，然后你可以把这个 URL 写在源码注释里，说：“这就是这里的意图。”这就更棒了，因为现在它可以直接把人们带到那个正则表达式，他们可以看到反编译的结果。我现在经常养成这种习惯：要么放一个指向这种工具的链接，要么放一个指向 Wolfram Alpha 的链接。你会在代码里经常看到这种情景：比如角度等于——然后是余弦除以这个再乘以那个，然后是那个的幂。接着人们
are just kind of scratching their head. So things like i'll put a link to wolf from alpha yeah i think for for you know big equate treat it maybe the salient point here is treat a regular expression like a complicated math equation and kind of give the right context man you got the life pro tips buried here down at the end of the podcast man yeah people got to stay till the end they have to listen to uh yeah stay to the end great tips at the end that's right yeah producer please make a note of that let's make sure folks catch the end of it are you just talking to yourself now jason yeah okay oh man very cool well this was awesome yeah i think you know we covered a language that we've we've uh this was a user request, actually, it's a multi, multi user request. Over the years, tons of folks have asked us to talk about Perl. You know, I think you can't talk about Perl without talking about regular expressions. And so we're able to kind of cover both of those, like almost a double header here. And, you know, thanks everyone for listening, staying till the end. And we appreciate it.
就只能在那挠头抓耳。所以诸如我会放一个指向 Wolfram Alpha 的链接……是的，我觉得对于大型等式，这里最突出的要点可能是：像对待一个复杂的数学方程式那样对待正则表达式，并给出合适的上下文。老兄，你把人生经验的精华都埋藏在播客的结尾了，老兄！对啊，大家必须坚持到最后，必须听完……对啊，坚持到最后，结尾有超棒的技巧！没错，是的，制片人请记一下这个，一定要确保大家听到结尾。你现在是在自言自语吗，杰森？对，好吧。噢天哪，太棒了！这真的太棒了。是的，我觉得我们今天聊了一门语言，这其实是一个用户的请求，准确地说，是多个用户的请求。多年来，无数的人要求我们聊聊 Perl。你知道的，谈论 Perl 就不能不谈论正则表达式。所以我们能够把这两者结合起来，就像是一场双重主打的节目。谢谢大家的收听，感谢大家坚持到最后，我们非常感激。
And thanks again for all your support. See you next time. Music by Eric Barndoller. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次感谢大家的所有支持。我们下期再见。音乐由 Eric Barndoller 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音和改编，但你必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。